the garbage yes the garbage garbage i
have to talk to you about a man named
jenk yuger of the young turks and i
don't want to because he's just a pundit
but when we're dealing with an internal
conflict that is effectively an
existential threat you need to
understand the sentiment that exists
among
some of these individuals on the
establishment side jankuger tweets
right wing doesn't love putin just
because he is an authoritarian
tyrannical leader they love him because
he's a white authoritarian leader race
has become more important than even
nationality they've turned on democ on
democracy and now even america in favor
of a white warlord
this may be one of the most insane
things i've ever read
nowhere in these incoherent ramblings
was there even a semblance of a thought
yet this man has millions of followers
and does
actually have influence over a large
portion of the political discourse in
this country
joe biden is an old white man yep who
is is leading the empire of the united
states according to the young turks
themselves and many of the left the u.s
is the empire is the fascist empire so
is joe biden not a white tyrannical
authoritarian apparently not apparently
it's putin but please show me
where right-wing individuals are
cheering for what putin is doing nowhere
jank huger highlights tucker carlson
saying it proves him right because
tucker explained what putin's mentality
was that's it and i think that's
important to understand right is it not
it is yeah when when dealing when
dealing with who is
right now your enemy is it not
good to understand the mentality that
they have it's necessary to perhaps come
to some sort of solution
yeah you know absolutely they don't want
it it's it's this typical rhetoric today
where you don't even attempt to
understand the other side
you just declare that they are wrong
and and hate them yeah i would like to
to understand putin's side i think i
don't i'm not like yay i wish he was my
leader but i under he's a i think as a
general goes if i was like playing a
video game and i wanted to put a guy in
command of my military i'd pick him over
biden or xi jinping who are both
bureaucrats this guy's got like military
experience he's xkgb he's cold as ice he
doesn't show emotion on his face he's a
good commander now ethically that's a
whole other discussion and we have
different russia and the united states
come from different places and we have
different ethics and morals um
that's another conversation but i have
that appreciation for the guy that for
his abilities but but
it's bringing it back to what the us is
facing but it's not because he's white
and that what shank you said is
completely racist well it's not it's not
just that it i don't care what
there's no substance here it doesn't
matter
the the ideas he's trying to convey what
matters is that
i i he he's just not well okay it's
white people attacking white really
disturbing you know it's what does this
have to do with race this is this is
typical again talking about priorities
of of the you know of the american
mindset
this is what we're worried about we're
worried about white authoritarian
leaders how about just the fact that
people are dying the young turks was a
genocidal group of turks in the early
1900s led by enverpasha that basically
created the armenian genocide it's
basically they did why would he name his
company the young turks
changed the name yeah check dude why i
just want to know why it's a cool
sounding name i said listen no it's
because
look man
i don't want to be overly reductive
here's a guy spouting that they love
putin i i certainly don't love putin i
don't know but mate so so you know i'm
not gonna assume he's talking about me
i'm that right wing right no i'm not
talking about me he calls me right
without being in love with the guy jenk
calls me right wing whenever they do
segments about me certainly whatever
that means fine but to imply that i am
involved in any kind of love for putin
is psychotic
jank yuger doesn't i don't think he
reads i don't think he pays attention
and i think he actually look i'm going
to come out and say it
he named his organization the young
turks
a genocidal group of people
he even denied the existence of the
armenian genocide until until i think
like 10 years ago or something like that
so even while he had the young turks
like it never happened or something like
that and then he apologizes for it i can
respect the apology for 100.
bro change the name of your organization
it's like a and this is something that
comes up all the time but this dude has
the nerve to come out and claim the
right loves putin because he's an
authoritarian radical leader dude
literally names his organization after
people who carried a genocide and
refuses refuses to change its name
dude don't get your moral lessons from
these people this tweet should be enough
to know this dude's lost his mind and
this is coming from the authoritarian
left i mean
these are the same people that champion
antifa you know and and and exactly it's
such cognitive dissonance they're
talking about authoritarian leaders what
have we been experiencing over the past
two years with mandates
these people have championed you know
rule by mandate sort of governance rule
by decree rule by decree
is he does he support that i haven't
really followed that he doesn't talk
i would go ahead well i i would go ahead
and bet heavily i would yeah i would go
ahead and bet heavily that he was
pro-lockdown uh that he was probably pro
uh vaccine mandate
um and all that and if i'm if i'm wrong
correct me um but coming from that
portion of the left these are people
that love
love big government look at look at this
when it caters to them you know look i i
hate to talk about him because he needs
this kind of attention he doesn't he
doesn't nearly get as much attention as
he used to whatever
he says i'm sure the fake left in
america tulsi gabbard etc who are still
pretending to be progressive are livid
about this attack on civil rights let
alone putin's unmitigated imperialism
i'm sure those pundits and award-winning
journalists are speaking out forcefully
right
yes russia arresting protesters is wrong
100
what world does this man live in or his
followers that they think the right
likes putin because he's a white
tyrannical leader and that they're happy
he's arresting people this is a
fabricated rally that doesn't exist yeah
where where where's the evidence that
that that thought even has been put out
there by anybody credible that
represents
yeah the right i really don't like
assumptions in general yeah i mean
that's just one of those things where
it's like at least show me a tweet from
somebody who's got as many followers as
you do that has that has said like yeah
putin go get um
exactly it's
i mean it's these people love creating
enemies where there is none and
boogeyman's where there are none it's
the weird thing is it's like these p you
said these people it changed changed it
didn't used to be he's same guy but
different behavior he used to be real
anti-war and really like talk about
right now he'd be talking about iraq if
it was 2007 and like how we are the
reason that other countries are invading
i know he knows that but to get hung up
on this crap man
i think and he's just doubled down and
gone crazy with him
but listen listen
obviously what he said was insane
obviously the right
is not cheering for protesters being
arrested who are opposing this obviously
they're not out there supporting putin
he's trying to make it seem like because
tucker carlson says that putin does not
like western influence in ukraine here's
the perspective that it's support of
putin but then what happens is a bunch
of other american establishment left
personalities defend his incentive
yeah for tribal reasons
because the right now mocks genter
they're going to come out he's right
it's a fact now his psychotic statement
is now a fact among these leftists the
battle of cult world and ignore ignoring
the fact that what tucker carlson is
saying is a mere fact
yeah tucker talking about the fact that
vladimir putin is uh hostile towards
western european influence is a fact
that's not that's not a
it's not a supporting statement of any
kind there's no emotion in that
statement that is a black and white fact
they said he echoed putin's talking
points echoed he literally told his
audience what putin said he's educating
oh yeah it's it's amazing his job is to
echo talking points i believe putin says
the that that the the the the ukrainian
administration is a western puppet and
then tucker cross on in his show says
vladimir putin views ukraine as a
western puppet
the the in 2014 you know the ousting of
yanukovych and they're like he's echoing
his talking points well how else is
supposed to tell people what's happening
in that country i feel like what
i feel like this is a step further on
the removing the context thing like what
they did with joe rogan he said the
n-word supposedly whatever they
completely removed all contacts they
made it seems like he was insulting
someone so now what they do with tucker
say he's echoing his talking points just
by saying that this is what he said he's
reporting the news he's telling his
journalists exactly he actually is a
journalist in fact that's misleading
telling someone someone's talking points
is different than echoing though exactly
echoing is claiming that you agree with
it and you're repeating it right exactly
echoing would be like yeah and i think
that's really bad too exactly i'll put
it this way the way tucker explained
what was going on he spoke factually but
it was very much
it's
there are certain things that are
happening in ukraine that vladimir putin
has stated which are
easy facts
simply by saying here's a fact of
something that happened in ukraine
the issue is
us corporate press lies
they've been they lied about joe biden
they lied about joe biden as quid pro
quo and if you tell the truth on that
you're echoing putin
joe biden absolutely engaged in a legal
quid program we're talking about his
charisma and vladimir putin sees that
and he says
so
the prosecutor in the administration is
fired because putin uh because i'm sorry
because biden
uh
threatened to to take away illegally
mind you
aid from the united states it's so
obviously an american puppet that
country oh you're you're you're that
you're equing putin now that that
celebrities
see how that works now now just by
observing
corruption
you are now in support technically
so the russian agendas are in support of
me because it was my i saw it coming two
years ago and i claimed it then
the selinsky stuff is not dude biden
goes in there
he he basically i don't know what you
would call browbeated the president to
fire a guy that was uh examining his a
company that his son was on the board of
so the president fired the guy
and then went by and then when that was
when biden was a vp when he left office
after trump gets in the guy comes back
he bragged about it he bragged about it
on stage yeah we've talked about this so
many times it's so important to
understand this but in video of him
doing it same time say that then you're
echoing you know russian propaganda
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there